now to capitol hill where judge katanji
brown jackson did as much listening as
speaking yesterday during her supreme
court confirmation hearing
several republican senators questioned
her on issues that matter to the party's
voters including critical race theory
over 13 hours jackson was also asked
about her philosophy cole killian was on
capitol hill where the hearing continues
this morning nicole good morning to you
i went out to dinner last night got home
at nine i couldn't believe she was still
sitting there what a very long day for
the judge yeah and it could be another
long day for judge jackson gail but look
the white house and democrats are
dismissing some of these questions from
republican senators they say they
crossed the line and are even pushing on
smears based on conspiracy theories
out of the gate judge katanji brown
jackson addressed the elephant in the
room as a mother
and a judge i was thinking
that nothing could be further from the
truth jackson refuted debunked claims by
missouri republican senator josh hawley
that she issued lenient sentences in
child pornography cases we're talking
about eight-year-olds and nine-year-olds
and year olds and 12 year olds
he's got images of these the government
said added up to over 600 images help me
understand that what word would you use
if it's not heinous or egregious
how would you describe it it is
heinous it is
egregious
what a judge has to do
is determine
how to sentence defendants
proportionately
it wasn't the only issue senate
republicans raised as texas senator ted
cruz also brought up critical race
theory questioning jackson's role on a
private school board are you comfortable
with these ideas being taught to
children
senator i have not reviewed any of those
books when senator cruz was asked how
this is relevant to the supreme court he
said critical race theory is divisive
there's too much division in our country
and
i think it is
concerning
if we have justices who are
embracing that view but by and large i
think you're doing very well
and as you can see this is a bit of a
tough place the majority of questions
from both sides of the aisle centered on
judge jackson's judicial philosophy i do
not believe that there is
a
a living constitution i must admit that
i don't really have a justice that i've
molded myself after or that i would what
i have is a record a record that almost
brought the judge to tears as she talked
about the challenges of balancing
motherhood i said in my opening
that
girls you know you had to deal with me
juggling motherhood and
job responsibilities and i i didn't
always get the balance
right
and so i would
hope for them seeing me um
moved to the supreme court
that they can know that you don't have
to be
perfect
in your
career trajectory and you can still
end up doing what you want to do
back to some of those questions from
senator holly he doubled down telling me
he thought judge jackson's responses
were excuses and that he can't vote for
someone like that but in the end it may
not matter because democrats don't
necessarily need gop votes to confirm
her vlad
and there will be more questions today
nicole killian for us thank you very
much